Hello everybody!
I'm finally gonna get to try out Helldive!
Okay, I'll say it before I start.
Fuck that one guy in my chat that was like, I'm gonna log into Helldive so Dokicat log in and get into a server.
Like, fuck you!
What is wrong with you?
Alright, so basically, I was like, I didn't realize...
Okay, so like, I've been in tutorial for like two hours now because I was scared.
And then I was like asking in chat, I was like, okay guys, cause like when I got in, it was like, oh server is at capacity, please try again later.
So like, you know, I've never played Helldivers before by the way.
I've never played Helldivers 1 and I've never fucking tried out Helldivers 2 because I was like, oh, I'm gonna try it out.
I was like, okay, if I'm gonna play Helldivers, I wanna play it on stream for the first time with you guys.
Cause like, I had friends being like, you guys wanna play Helldivers?
I was like, no!
I'm gonna do this for my dragoons.
But then everyone was like, good luck getting in.
I was like, what do you mean, good luck getting in?
So then, I was like, asking my chat, also, Mom, thank you for the...
Machete Super, thank you, cheese.
Anyway, I apologize.
I'm a wizard.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Anyway, so I was like, asking in my chat, I was like, hey guys, so like, I'm in the tutorial.
Does this count?
And then, so like, obviously, the first two people were like, yeah, if you're in the tutorial right now, that means you're in the server.
So I was like, sweet!
And then right after that, one guy, I swear, if that one guy was correct, they're like, no, you're not in the server.
And I was like, oh.
So I was just like, oh, no, wait a minute.
And then, so then I was like, guys, please, I need to know.
Cause like, being in the tutorial doesn't mean being in the game.
Then, we are so fucked.
Cause like, I could just finish the tutorial right now, before the stream.
So then people, one person was like, no, you're okay.
You're in the game, you're in the server.
And I was like, nice.
And at the moment I wrote, nice, one other guy was like, no, you're not.
So I was just like, okay, well, we're gonna do it.
I swear to God, I feel like I'm gonna crash.
Cause like, people were like...
People were like, oh yeah, I mean, you could be in.
But like, that doesn't stop you from crashing.
And I was like, wait.
What do you mean?
It doesn't stop you from...
Oh, no!
Cause apparently when you crash, obviously you have to go back in there again.
So like, I'm just like, please.
Please, just at least let me finish the tutorial.
Also, Amelia, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
What do you call Helldiver squad?
Composed of Tyler Dragoons, Freebirds!
Thank you again.
Alright, so, yeah.
I just wanna do my part and squash some bugs for democracy.
So, let's get this started.
Where am I?
Alright, I've been like...
I don't even remember what happened.
Cause I've been like, looking at this.
Earn your cape.
Check your map to...
Oh, I want a cape.
I wanna be cool.
Alright.
Time to find the one guy.
Alright, here we go.
I've never played Helldivers.
I'm actually going in blind.
I heard it's really, really fun though with friends.
Alright, instructors, we'll see you on the other side.
Alright.
This is where all your tax dollars go to.
Honestly, I'm glad this is where all my tax dollars are going to.
Alright, nice.
The upcoming obstacles will take everything your exceptional physique can possibly take.
Let me see.
What about control?
Wait, what does control do then?
It's a real deal.
Get to it, soldier.
Alright.
I feel like I should have done this already before I got signed.
Like, before I'm in the field.
You know?
I feel like I showed the bugs why I was man who was made in God's image.
That was so fast and point.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm a realistic battlefield simulator.
That's right.
Okay.
Oh!
Sorry.
I did it too soon.
Don't worry.
It'll be different.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
It will not be different.
What do you mean?
Okay.
Alright.
I'll have to dive in.
Okay.
Then what?
After that, what happens?
What do I do after that?
Boom.
What do you mean?
Oh, my God.
I'm doing my part.
Well, I think of a magenta super thing.
Okay.
Alright.
Do I hold up?
What?
I can't hold on.
I can't get off.
Oh, don't hold shift.
Okay.
Oh, my fucking God.
That's not me.
I swear.
Look at us.
I'm going to get up.
Oh, my.
Look at all these bodies.
That's definitely not me.
Thank you.
That's good.
That won't happen to me in the real game.
E.
What?
How's the volume, by the way?
Grab a stim?
Where's the stim?
Oh, in front of me.
Okay.
V.
Alright.
Nice.
Yeah.
That wasn't me.
That was a different player.
You miss a bit load?
Okay.
Let me fix the volume real fast.
Boop.
I'll boost it up.
I don't know if sound guy's here today.
Let me...
Yeah.
Sound guy's not here.
I don't know actually if sound guy's here today.
Imagine that...
Oh, yes.
If you didn't fucking run.
Everybody runs.
Oh, my God.
I'm so sorry.
No.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
This is way too low to sense.
Alright.
Mouse sensitivity.
I don't...
Okay.
Mouse scope...
Mouse...
Why is it on 10?
Okay.
Mouse aim should definitely not be on 10.
Let me fix that real fast.
Okay.
Let me...
No.
That's way too high.
The best part about being a gamer is that you're super anal about...
You're super focused.
You're super fucking anal when it comes to...
Oh, I have no bullets.
When it comes to sensitivity.
Step one.
Grab a fistful of freedom.
Send the swarm something warm.
Step two.
Penetrate and detonate.
Maximum death for maximum damage.
Terminate the...
Termin...
Headshot.
Nice.
More cheese, man.
Thank you for the aqua soup.
Thank you.
Alright.
So, I'm going to...
Is that it?
Where are the ones that keep coming?
Oh, pick up the grenades!
Okay.
Sorry.
I keep forgetting that I can't read.
How do I throw?
G to throw a grenade?
What do I throw?
In there?
Boop!
Nice!
Super destroyer.
Okay.
Ice.
Use a stratagem now to take care of those...
Stratagem?
Just make sure you take a few steps back.
How do I do this?
Orbital WASD to die...
Oh!
Activating.
I'm doing it!
Where is it?
Oh, throw it!
I'm doing it!
For real this time!
Sorry!
I keep forgetting to read.
Okay, now I got it.
It's okay, I'm doing it now.
I'm reading it!
I'm learning how to read, guys!
Look, you normally don't have to read in other FPS games.
Reading is a little hard.
How's the sound now?
Is it better?
Nice.
Yeah, it's just frie- yeah!
See?
It's like- it's just life!
Voice is a bit low?
Okay, don't worry, I got you guys!
Alright, that should be better.
Alright, control the whole strat- again?
Oh!
Okay.
Activating.
Throw the stratagem ball.
Right there, here.
Here?
Reinforce.
Whoa.
Greetings, soldier!
Are you doing your part?
If you don't do your part, you know what's gonna happen.
Just like America!
America!
Alright, what's this?
Moving makes it hard.
Stand still for maximum- But I don't wanna stand still.
Oh shit, whoops.
That's so easy.
What do I have to do to have Doki shoot me too?
Thank you for the Akasufa meme.
Thank you, thank you.
That it?
Oh, I need to throw it in.
Thank you for getting me to throw it in.
Nice.
Woo!
Mill Mouse for first person?
It's not activating first- I think you have to get out of tutorial first.
To activate first person.
Don't reload.
Oh wait!
The mag is left up- What?
Really?
That's so dumb!
I'm so used to reloading all the time.
I just activate it here.
Oh!
Why would I ever- I'm gonna- I'm just gonna Fortnite this.
I- I don't think I would- This is actually disgusting.
I'm sorry!
This actually looks fucking terrible.
It's not for me.
Hold the reload button.
You're- I mean, look- look at this!
It's so gross!
Like- I need to hold R for- Oh!
That's so interesting.
Alright, what is this?
Press 1, 2, 3 to swap your support or your- Uh...
What's my support gun?
Okay.
What is this?
Okay, what is this?
Do I have everything?
Alright, here we go.
I mean, it's so gross.
I can just- I can just aim in third person cause I'm not...
stupid.
This is not a competitive shooting!
Okay, maybe if I'm sniping- I'll do this.
Woah!
I might not be able to read!
But I know I'm not that stupid!
Wait, is that it?
What do I do?
Retrieve the flag of Super Earth.
Oh my god.
What's the difference between regular Earth and Super Earth?
More democracy?
I'm heading over!
What do I plant it here?
Is this where Super Earth goes?
Okay, no.
Oh, salute!
Press B to salute.
Sorry, I pressed N.
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Where's my other gun?
Where's my- There you go.
Oh, shit!
There's your granade!
If I- Hold left!
Oh, I need a grenade!
I need a grenade!
Oh, I don't need a grenade.
Super Earth has a cape!
Thank you, with the Super Chat!
I'm gonna- Thank you, thank you.
I know, right?
I'm so fucking good at this.
I can wear a cape!
I'm ready!
Dragons!
I'm just like you and- I have a younger me.
I'm doing my part!
Oh my god, it's it!
Justice!
Oh my god, that one...
Okay, to be fair, if it really takes like less than like 15 minutes to train a soldier to go to war, I don't think like we're winning this war.
I get the cool cape though!
But guys, I get a cool fucking cape!
Justice, welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Monster Envy, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Regular Earth was destroyed in the first game.
Along with a bunch of super earths, they just move on to a new world and call it Super Earth.
It's mine now, smile.
Smile.
Oh god, I like this song.
I feel the democracy right now.
I really do feel the freedom.
Oh shit!
Wait, I can change my name?
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
I wanna be called...
WINGS!
Wings of pride, of science, of starlight, of super wings of the people.
Okay, wait.
Of war, of victory, of twilight, of truth, of the stars.
Oh my god, what do we want wings of?
Wings of law.
Oh yeah, definitely not honor.
Of authority!
No, wait, wait, no.
Of democracy.
Wings of...
There was one that actually won.
Where was it?
Destruction, there we go.
Alright, doesn't matter whose side gets destroyed.
I'm here for it.
Wings of destruction.
Is that me?
Where's my Kate?
Hello.
I got in the server.
You're in charge of this vessel now.
The democracy officer awaits you on the bridge.
Welcome to the galactic war.
I'm doing my part.
Open your so- here you can see your friends activities and join a mission.
Alright.
Well, we're doing it solo.
We might try to queue like randoms and then have people yell at me.
Also, is the sound a lot better now?
Guys?
How's the sound so far?
My sound guy's not here so I don't know.
May liberty guide me.
What is orders?
Have launch, kill 60 enemies using.
It's okay now?
Sound is good?
Alright, nice.
I don't want it to be too loud.
That's really it for the background.
Go to the story bridge and use the- Okay, apparently, people were yelling at me and was like, Do not customize your character or you will crash.
So, like, I'm gonna make sure I don't customize.
The galaxy awaits your salvation.
Alright.
Where are you?
Here at war, you may cast your vote many times.
Alright.
Once on election day and another with every bullet bearing in an enemy combatant.
The freedom of the galaxy- Where do I go?
Welcome to the galactic war.
Here, the community fights together against its common enemy.
The path to the barrier of planets is clear.
Upon each barrier of planets, engineers have begun construction of the Termin- Termin- control system, a network of massive towers that will cover each planet in the well-tested neurotoxins known as termicide.
Soon, our citizens will be able to rest easy, knowing their children are safe from the threats of being eaten alive.
But, like, are we the- But, did they live on the planet first?
Or did we live on the planet first?
Doesn't matter because they're the bad guys.
Because they're not about democracy!
Was that- Is that it?
Am I- Am I fitting in?
Am I-
Doesn't matter because they're not about freedom and democracy!
We deserve that planet!
Hovering over a sector shows you how much of its super- Earth has already been liberated.
Do not worry, in- in-sects!
We will liberate you!
Um...
All operations contribute to pushing the enemies of super-Earth back.
Select a sector to see what planets are currently playable.
Alright.
Is this...
So, this is...
This is our planet.
So I guess we just go here, right?
Depending on the war progress, different planets will be available.
Select a planet to see what operations are available.
Oh, wait, they're 100% liberated already.
Oh shit, we gotta go in!
Alright.
Operation is a collection.
Okay, we're gonna go liberate.
Alright.
Spread democracy.
Raise the super-flag as an un-assailable beacon of liberty.
Don't worry, I'm coming in!
Wings of destruction is coming in!
To deliver freedom!
They definitely do not want me as a teammate, but it's too bad.
Shots fired.
I- Oh, hey guys!
I'm level one!
Um...
I'm just a little baby.
Babyyyyyy.
Do not worry!
You didn't need any help!
But I'm coming in anyway!
Joe, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Don't worry, Doki Bird.
You're manifesting destiny right now.
Nice, that's good to know.
Give me a sec, I'm still figuring this out.
Alright.
What do I- S-O-S?
Wait, I didn't- What- What's going on?!
I didn't get to see what was going on!
Where am I?!
I'm so confused!
Um...
Yes?
Is- Is this it?
Don't worry, I put- Push to talk.
Am I ready?
Wait, am I open mic?
No, no, I already changed it.
I already changed it to push to talk.
Don't worry guys, I made sure to change it to push to- I'm so confused.
But I think I'm ready.
It's okay!
This man's level 21!
There's no way I can fuck up!
He's literally level 21!
We can do this!
We can spread democracy!
We can get carried!
That's all that matters!
There's no way it's over!
We literally have a guy that's- First off, his name is Chief.
Second off, he's level 21.
Like, how can I fuck up?
Come on!
I'm confused and ready to do my part.
Alright!
Here I am!
Who's C3?
Oh, what are we doing?
Guard dog!
Okay!
What are you guys- What are you guys doing?
Biggest- Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I'm- I'm a little confused, but I have- Who's the- Who's like the strongest one?
Who's the- New ta- Oh, they're calling in their weapons!
Do I have any weapons?
Sorry.
I don't- Call in your M- I don't need my MG!
I don't need my MG!
I need my MG!
Don't worry!
I will do my part!
I can aim!
We don't need MG's!
Guys!
That is- I can aim!
That's my part!
Fuck!
I forgot not to reload.
I need to remember not to reload.
Don't worry.
Here I am.
I'm on baby difficulty?
Then what are you guys saying about these level 21's on baby difficulty, huh?
What does that say about them?
Who are they calling?
They're calling so many things!
I'm doing my part.
Oh shit!
Oh shi- I can't see!
I'm doing it.
Don't worry.
They're the babysitters!
It's fine!
We're so good!
We're so good at this game!
Oh, I love my team!
I love my team!
For freedom and liberty!
Seeing isn't mandatory.
You do not need to see anything.
All you need to do is shoot.
So what do we do now guys?
Where is this song playing from?
You know what?
I do feel the freedom right now.
I do feel this freedom.
Oh I just loot the flag.
You're right.
We gotta wait for the flag.
I feel so patriotic with everything going on.
Oh oh!
Is there bugs behind us?
There's bugs behind us.
Don't worry.
We can do this.
What do I do?
Do I need a machine gun?
Nah.
Glory to Super Earth!
Yay!
Did someone die?
Oh my god!
What happened?
How did you die?
How the fuck did this guy die?
Did we save him?
How did we get across?
Did he step on the mine?
Did he step on... No!
The other baby!
Hahaha!
I... oh... oh... oh...
I hope I don't step on the mine.
He ran over the mine.
See guys?
I'm not the baby here.
Guys... I wasn't the baby here.
I didn't step in any mines.
Freedom comes at a cost, Doki.
You think it's gonna be easy?
Defend extraction zone.
I can do that.
Alright, use all your materials.
I'll just shoot my gun.
Little baby man.
He died a hero.
You either die a hero or you die... or you live as a coward.
Isn't that right guys?
Freedom is free.
That one guy.
Thank you Super Chef.
Thank you.
We need more men at the creek for Super Earth.
Look!
I'm doing my part!
I'm shooting my gun!
Is that nice?
Oh my god.
This is the... this has to be the easiest game of my life.
Oh shit.
I shouldn't have reloaded.
Fuck.
I...
Oh my god.
So easy.
This game's been out for like a week and it's already got first community.
Shake my head.
Look.
See?
Look at that.
So easy.
Orbital inbound.
Wait.
Whoa!
Man down!
Oh shit.
I can't see!
I'm slowed!
We're good.
Fire at hostile state clear on the field.
Nice.
Oh we got clear landing zone.
See I can listen.
This is it?
Where is it?
Oh my god.
It's coming in.
The freedom's coming in.
Oh!
The baby!
Oh my god!
Please!
I'm a good person I swear!
Hahaha!
Oh I'm so scared!
I'm too scared I'm going in!
I'm too scared!
I'm scared he's gonna shoot me too!
I went inside and don't want him to shoot me!
I don't...
Hahaha!
He would... he would just witness the murder.
That's a true friendly fire!
This horror is on!
Oh my god!
They smell gunpowder.
I... I smell democracy.
We are not the same!
Hahaha!
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
Witness...
I witnessed a fucking murder!
I got so scared!
Hahaha!
Oh my god!
Yay!
Glorious victory!
Hahaha!
The other baby... that could have been me!
Guys!
I could have been the baby that got shot!
Hahaha!
Look at that!
First game!
First liberation!
Marines, we are leaving!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Yay!
It was a lesson!
Hahaha!
Woo!
Oh my god!
This guy is like... suit is like decked out already!
Alright, I'm going back.
Where am I?
Okay, return to ship.
I unlocked... What difficulty was I in if I unlocked easy?
Excuse me?
There's a difficulty below zero?
Hahaha!
What difficulty was I in?
Guys, I unlocked easy.
I can't believe it guys!
I can't believe I unlocked easy!
Alright, new customize... No, I'm too scared to customize after like...
That one chatter was like, do not customize!
How do I... How do I move this?
I wanna... I wanna go do war.
How come it won't let me do war?
I wanna leave this group.
Hahaha!
I don't wanna leave this...
I'm done playing with you.
Hahaha!
Go back to my ship.
Whose ship is this?
Is this your ship?
Wait...
Return to ship alone.
Alright, see you guys.
I'm done playing with you guys.
Nice.
Oh, I'm in like cryo.
I just realized.
It's the other baby ship.
Alright, I'm done playing with... with... with that team.
Oh, what is this?
Go to ship manager to acquire new strategy and upgrade your destroyer.
I can upgrade my ship now?
And upgrade... You can use this turn to manage your destroyer of whatever which... which your vessel is on.
Okay.
To use on initially destroyer only has access to a limited category.
Okay, so like all I have is like baby shit right now.
Oh!
Anti... Okay, I want the rifle.
Oh, I don't have money.
Alright, don't worry.
I can get carried by all the other ones.
By all the other level 20s.
Hahaha!
How much money do I have?
Oh my god, I am so poor right now.
Alright.
Here we go.
Alright, don't worry.
We can keep on...
doing the... the democrat stuff.
Friendly fire is in.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, we gotta find a new place to protect.
Quick play.
I wanna do quick play.
Wait, do I have...
Do I have medium now?
Guys!
I can do medium!
Alright, reduced.
Okay.
Okay, who's...
40 minutes.
Okay.
Can this guy kill me?
Can this guy carry me?
Can this guy...
How do I leave this planet?
Oh, okay.
There we go.
Okay, I wanna do medium.
Wait, no.
I wanna do easy.
I have to complete easy first?
Okay.
Don't worry.
I'm ready to liberate.
I need like...
Here.
Failed to jump.
No, please!
No!
Why did it fail to join?
Oh, this guy.
Find and destroy all the eggs.
No!
Please!
Let me do all the...
Oh, there we go.
Please.
I need as many people to spread freedom as possible.
Mission 4.
Allied destroyed.
Hey, guys.
Level 28!
Let's go!
Let's fucking go!
You wanna click on basically what you can, which is gonna be machine gun shit and...
Oh my god!
He's teaching our little baby!
He has a baby too!
Okay.
Bro, he's like watching TV while playing right now.
Like, his PC is like in his living room, I think.
I wanna be like, what are you watching?
Yes!
Wait, what is a super... what is a super citizen?
Well, I get like DMCA'd by this one guy watching on his TV.
I'm gonna go to the bathroom.
Like, the one guy that's... it's like, Scrubs has DMCA'd you.
Yeah, you can see his TV.
I love games like this, dude.
This literally is just Star Shrouds reverse.
Oh my god, look at him!
He's an ODS dude.
He's a PS5 gamer?
Which one?
The... the... I like how the...
Stand by.
Um... DMCA'd by someone's game.
Someone's game.
Yeah.
You call home, your left bumper, and call in your machine gun.
Oh my god, he is on controller!
Alright, don't worry.
I know how to do this too.
Machine gun, reply reinforced.
There you go.
Boom!
I'm learning!
Where's my thing?
Be right back.
Oh, there he is.
Nice.
I got my stuff.
Plus a barrel.
Can I steal his shit?
Right now, shut up.
Alright, nice.
Alright, I'll throw this.
Nice.
Look at the little baby!
Oh my god!
He's like a dad teaching his...
Teenagers... teenage son how to play the game!
Wait, what's my mission?
I was not paying attention.
What if she was open mic?
No, I'm not.
I made sure I was not open mic.
Wait, where's our super citizen?
Who's our super sis?
C3, right?
Oh my god, look at them go.
Bug breach detected.
Don't worry!
The babies will stay in the back!
Go dads!
Go!
Oh shit!
I thought someone hit me.
I was just wondering where all the eggs are.
Don't worry!
The babies will be here in the back line!
Oh, the baby!
There's babies in the back too!
Don't worry.
I got it.
I don't want to side... Oh fuck!
Okay.
Oh my god, I'm getting raped.
Oh!
No!
I got fucking surrounded.
Oh no!
When your friends die, you have to call them back in.
With the strat again.
Oh.
That's right.
Oh no!
No!
Okay.
Please don't let him get me!
And then fucking...
Heal teammates.
I'm not fucking healing jack shit.
We did it!
Bug holes, you just chuck a nade in them.
Kind of like grab holes, yeah?
We did it guys!
We did it!
I took a turretle rifle.
What the fuck?
Now I know... Now I realize why...
We normally don't do open vs... Like why we don't go into voice chat.
It's so hard to like listen to my class and do this.
Now...
Yeah, okay.
He's in class!
Did you guys see that?
You all looking at him.
He's in class right now!
Yeah, I was looking at that.
It's kind of rad.
Bro!
He's like, bro it's so hard to play right now while listening to my class.
What a fucking... Oh my god.
Bro!
I won't be like... What's your... Why are you learning right now?
It wasn't even TV!
He's literally playing video games while in class.
It's good to just take out all these albums and stuff.
Holy shit.
Bro, he's the teacher, bro.
He's the teacher.
Yeah, I was like, I'm fucking... I'm just trying to figure out shit.
He's just like me for real.
For real.
Guys, we're getting a free lesson while we're playing too.
Guys, we're getting a free lesson right now, chat.
Whatever he's learning at the moment.
Take your notes!
That's great.
That's actually great.
Look at that!
You don't have to pay tuition!
You can literally learn everything from my stream!
Is he gonna be on the test?
Doki!
Is there gonna be a quiz on this later?
Later!
Bitch!
So, some of these areas there will be like supplies too that we can pick up.
Okay.
That let us upgrade our...
Yeah, here you go.
...stuff later on.
That is super... Oh my god, he's actually like teaching me!
Am I stuck?
Yeah, he is.
Just get a Vandible.
You get one shot with it.
Oh, there you go.
Okay.
Knock it.
Oh fuck.
Oh my god!
I'm... I'm... He's like... He's actually babysitting me!
I got the super citizens.
They babysitting me.
Yo, free college.
Army, thank you for the magenta soup.
But thank you, thank you.
A true patriot.
Destroying enemies of super before the school.
Tuition down payment.
Yes, thank you for the super.
Nice.
Thank you.
Alright guys, what is he learning about anyway?
Encounter... Use your stratagem?
What do I use?
I don't know what to use so I'm just gonna shoot my gun.
Finally, the free education.
I've always wanted it.
Oh shit, there's a lot.
Oh god.
There's a bug breach!
No!
Don't worry, I'm helping!
No, I'm doing my part!
Oh god, I hope I'm not shooting.
Don't worry!
I got you, C3!
C3, no!
C3!
The super citizen!
I was hoping the other guy would do it.
Don't worry, I'm doing it!
I had to wait for chat to tell me!
I'm doing it!
So was that deactivated?
Guys, I'm sorry I'm too busy trying to pay attention to class right now!
Okay?
She did it!
Oh shit.
I did it, guys!
I'm doing it!
Dude has been maxing by getting history and thalassias.
Anthomology lessons.
What a true patriot.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, there's the others!
The others are here now!
What is this?
Whoa!
As an American, I appreciate the free education today.
This is the freedom we strive for.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't believe it.
This is what happens, guys.
This is true democracy.
We're getting education right now while killing insects?
What true... this is true democracy.
The American dream.
You're right.
We're living the dream right now!
You're so right.
Oh my god, I think I got like shot.
My shield got shot or some shit.
Nice, you destroyed the eggs.
Extractions available now.
I don't know what my push to talk button... what's the default push to talk button, guys?
You guys know?
Yeah.
Do you guys know?
I wanna ask him what he's learning.
I really wanna know what he's learning right now.
Tab?
Tab slot?
I'll be like, so what's your edu... what are you learning?
I'll ask him we're not fucking dying.
Can I enroll now?
Harris, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Ew!
Ew.
We must know.
We must know what he's learning.
Alright, nice.
Are you learning about freedom, son?
Mission at 30 minutes remaining.
Don't worry, we finished it, we're just extraction now.
It's extractions now.
Welcome to Tokyo.
I've got 10 minutes of class left.
Stop!
There's something weird to the left here.
It's like some medals or something.
We gotta finish this before class is over!
Guys!
Bro is not learning.
I don't know.
It's okay, dude.
Oh my god.
Guys!
We need to hurry before his class is over!
Or he won't be able to...
People will think it's suspicious if he's not leaving his class.
I guess we'll just extract here.
Whoa!
Ow!
I'm following C3.
We gotta do it for Super Earth and his education!
Okay, nice.
Nice.
Thank you, C3.
Thank you, Super Citizen!
Oh my god!
He smiled too!
He smiled at me!
Oh my god.
Look at him.
Team player.
Okay, okay.
I'll ask him later.
When we're not getting like...
When we're not trying to like, you know, survive.
I'm doing my part.
Where will he come from?
Ask him to turn up the volume.
No goons if you don't.
Bruce, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Not bad.
Not bad though.
Now he's asking us if we can hear him.
Bro!
I was like, wait, can you guys actually?
Nice.
Oh my god, I just got like 13 kills of better.
We're doing it.
Is there any other insects coming from this way or is it all from here?
I don't think we even need to shoot our guns.
Okay, I'll help this way.
Ask to compare notes.
He asked me like, How's your class going on right now?
Like...
Have you been like taking any notes?
Whoa!
Shit.
Jesus Christ.
Nice.
Extraction 26.
Okay, I'm gonna ask in like 10 seconds.
This is so calm compared to like the first one.
Oh, shit.
I'm not even playing on that hard.
In 10 seconds we'll ask them.
Ridiculous.
I can use my mini-map to see where the enemies are.
Constant onslaught.
Yeah, but I'm lazy.
Alright, here it is.
Here it is.
So what class is it?
I'm
talking!
He's so embarrassed!
You can extract your sets.
You'll never know!
You'll never know what class it was!
They're like, A woman!
So what class were you in?
That's uh...
MRI.
MRI?
So I'm doing a...
Fuck.
What are you... which class?
This is my uh...
I don't even know what he's learning!
It's the sequence parameters and shit.
Sequence parameters?
All about the peg, feg, and sec, and coding gradients, and fuckin' MROs.
But it's a review, so I'm like, I don't give a shit anymore.
He's so immense!
I'm like, I actually fucking did my homework, so I'm good.
Wait, he's a doctor?!
He's an actual doctor?!
Bro, oh he's a technician!
Oh my god!
Bro, he did his homework, guys!
Guys!
He did his fucking homework!
He doesn't give a fuck!
This is our future doctor!
Ready for freedom!
The technician for...
Oh my god.
I don't want this person to...
If I'm getting an MRI scan, and like, this is...
I'm leaving.
Goodbye.
He's a combat medic.
Guys, I can't believe it.
I basically gave you guys a free medical lecture.
Right there.
Okay, but if he's like...
If like...
MRI... There's something wrong with the MRI.
And he was too busy to like...
know what to do because he was playing Helldivers.
I would be scared.
I would be very scared.
A true patriot saving lives both as a medical staff and kill bugs.
Glory to Super Earth.
I mean, thank you for the Akka soup, but thank you.
Thank you.
Maj!
Good to know the medical future of Super Earth is in good hands.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I can't believe it.
We had a real doctor with us, guys!
Holy fuck!
We had a medical combat officer.
I was paying attention to his class more than he was.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, let's see.
Spread democracy.
Let's see.
Oh my god.
How was the volume throughout all of that?
I guess it was pretty good because you guys were able to listen to it.
It was class, right?
Choose where you will use your race.
I'm pretty sure it was all right because you guys could actually learn from his class.
Can I do the medium now?
Get down there and eradicate them.
Yeah, that was fine.
We heard everything.
Alright, one, one out of four.
Learned a lot.
I'm now a doctor.
I wanted to learn more from him.
You're like, Doki, why did you leave this team?
We could have learned so much!
We could have had another lecture!
There's nothing in medium, guys.
I literally can't find a medium planet.
Is there a medium planet here?
Have to complete a section to unlock... Oh, I need to complete a section to unlock this...
Okay, we gotta keep fucking saving the world.
Alright let's see, one outta four.
I could have had a higher education.
Guys, this is the strat!
Guys, no no, this is the strat guys, all we have to do...
...is, umm, we just keep fucking queuing up until we can find more doctors.
So like, instead of like going to school, we can leech off of their education.
Come on guys!
Think about fucking the chips.
Think about...
Thank you!
What the fuck is going on?
Alright.
Nice.
Who's our babysitter?
Wait, what?
Did they finish?
Did they fin- Where am I?
Am I- Wait!
They kicked me out already?!
I think they did it.
They're like, oh- I'm kicked from the game!
Bro!
I know I'm just a baby, but I wanna be included!
I can't believe I got kicked!
The Clutcher kicked me!
They saw the level and was like, no.
We cannot let this baby- play.
Okay, perch, hatchet trees.
Alright.
Can't join this team.
No women!
Alright, here we go.
Wait, we're all babies here.
This is not good.
Guys!
Where's our super citizen?!
Be gone, child!
Guys, this is not good!
Oh no!
We're the baby team!
Who's gonna hold my head?!
Where's our MRI tech?!
Don't worry babies!
It can't be that bad!
Oops, sorry, I keep forgetting.
Uhhhhhhhhhh...
This is my machine gun.
Oop!
I'm gonna get my machine gun.
Alright, let me get my machine gun.
Use your orb, laser, and star gem for a large group before they notice you.
Open the mini-map to see mission and side location.
Alright, how do I open my mini-map again?
Oh shit!
There's fall damage?!
I have armor!
Okay.
If I wear armor, there should be no fall damage.
That should be a rule.
That should be...
Oh, there it is.
Oh my god!
There it is!
You guys can't see it, but I'm looking at it right now.
I like just destroy the eggs from here.
Oh, I can.
I don't even have to walk over.
Nice.
Don't worry!
We are... we might be babies!
But babies are strong together!
Three babies can make one super citizen!
Oh!
Babies!
Guys, we all had one job.
Guys, what happened to our one job together?
We should be strong together, babies.
Here we go.
Wow, the difference between not getting killed...
Oh, I'm so happy.
I'm so happy.
It's a... it's a huge difference.
Oh, shit!
Why heal when I can make them heal for me?
Why use my own resources, guys?
What the fuck?
It's not...
I feel like I wasted that.
Babies together strong!
Okay.
It's alright.
It's okay.
This is fine.
I don't need ammo, guys.
Look at us go!
We're so strong!
Alright.
We're gonna get rid of all of these.
Okay.
I don't need the pistol.
It's alright.
We're destroying it!
We did it, guys!
Yoink.
Alright.
I swear, if I fucking get fall damage, I fucking swear.
Okay.
Now, I'm like so paranoid right now.
I'm actually so paranoid.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Do not worry.
Liberty is coming.
Oh, shit.
It's like, those birds that like lay their eggs on the side of the cliff and when they like, grow up, when they like, are at age, it- the parents like kick them out of the nest to learn how to fly.
If they don't fly, they just die.
That's us right now.
That's actually us right now.
It's time for us to fly, guys.
To spread democracy!
We must be kicked out of the nest.
Alright.
Oh, there's this one guy coming up.
Okay, I'm a little scared because I'm running out of ammo.
I need to like call my...
That's fucking right!
Guys, can we like move on?
It's okay, we don't have to kill them!
Spread the wings of freedom.
Who am I playing with?
I'm playing with a... well, my last partner was a doctor.
He was learning about MRIs.
Okay, let's see.
Where's the resupply?
I don't have the resupply.
What?
A quote-unquote doctor.
I hope he passes his exams.
Look, he did his homework guys.
You guys remember what he said?
He was like, I did the homework.
Do not retreat.
Defend liberty at all costs.
But my ammo!
I don't have... what are we doing?
Okay.
Oh no.
Oh no, the bugs are coming.
The bugs are coming.
Am I... alright.
I'm helping.
Okay.
But he passed the pills.
How do I demonstrate your MRI?
Is that worth it?
Would you want your MRI technique?
What do you mean?
If you don't have the mission to be like playing Helldivers?
I need to know.
If you're about to get an MRI scan and your doctor is out here playing Helldivers, and that is why your MRI scan is getting delayed.
Is that okay?
Hell, yeah.
If it's for freedom.
Fuck, yeah, it is.
Oh my god, I keep accidentally proning.
Okay.
Okay, do I have enough for resupply?
God damn it.
I would get an MRI scan by a patriot!
It's for a worthy cause!
That's fucking right!
Good answer!
It was a test all along!
Of fucking course you want your MRI scan by a goddamn American of super-hearts!
Yay!
We did it!
Get a super MRI.
All right, here we go.
Where are you going guys?
Babies!
Where are we going babies?
Hallelujah brothers!
Get a freedom MRI!
With extra freedom!
Why check map when I can just follow one person?
See?
I don't need to check anything.
They're doing it all for me.
Oh nice.
I need the ammo actually.
Nice.
Oh, is it more supplies?
Oh, more supplies.
I like that.
Oh, nice.
More reload.
The donation to further cause a managed democracy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Major.
Kaz, there won't be any bucks in that MRI!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I mean, oh shit!
Fucking yeah!
Fuck yeah, brothers!
Yeah, I feel bad taking that medal.
Like...
All right, nice.
Okay.
I just want to make sure I have...
enough ammo for...
Oh, hey!
It's daytime now!
Nice!
Oh?
There's like people behind us.
Wait, they can fly?!
Oh wait, they're bugs.
Of course they can fly.
All right.
It's all right.
We're fine.
You have to go like this way.
Nowhere.
Oh, the loot is shared?
Nice.
All right, guys.
Look, I can look at the map too!
I can look at the map too!
Oh, it's over here.
That's where they are.
Pull down to the machine gun.
All right, we gotta...
We gotta go kill the big mama.
You know what?
Fuck this.
I'm just gonna throw it.
I already have so many nades anyway.
It's fine.
I can aim.
Oh, great!
They fly now!
Wait, bug breach?
What does that mean?
Where is it coming from?
Where is the bug breach coming from?
Oh.
That means reload.
Reload!
Reloading!
Don't let him get any nades!
Don't touch me!
Oh shit.
Get the ones that fly!
We gotta put the ones that fly down!
Okay.
Liberty!
All right, we can go up, right?
I hope I get to go to medium difficulty soon.
I...
Here they come!
All right.
We gotta shoot them in the head.
Okay.
Please.
The drag for this.
Nice.
All right.
Can we go up?
Can we go up now?
Guys, we have enough violence!
I think I'm ready for medium.
Guys, it can't be that hard.
All right.
I'm going in.
I ain't afraid!
These guns are made for Super Earth!
All right.
We got rid of these guys.
Okay.
Please don't shoot me.
Woohoo!
Nice.
Extraction available.
Where do we go?
All right.
We gotta go to extraction.
Let's go, babies!
Let's go!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I'm gonna miss this.
Babies!
Let's go, babies!
I'm going the wrong way!
Don't follow me!
No!
Never mind!
Don't follow me!
All right.
The moment I tried to lead, I already went the wrong way.
Like, I don't...
I don't know.
For Super Earth...
The super special soldier...
I'm just directionally challenged!
What is this?
I got a sample.
What is it for?
Look, that's not my fault!
I just...
I'm gonna wait for them to interact.
What's this?
Do you need a transport?
Is there anything else to loot?
It took Doki longer to kill them than the actual one.
All right!
Thank you for the super chat, Tai!
Thank you!
All right.
Are you guys ready?
I'm not.
Okay.
All right.
We're ready.
All right, guys!
I don't think you guys were ready, but we're ready now.
You guys might have not actually been ready, but we're ready now, guys.
Do not worry!
We don't need a super citizen!
We are super together!
Baby's never ready.
There's enough of us to be ready!
Oh my god.
Wait, if this was easy, then why the fuck was that level 41 in the easy lobby?
What...
What is he doing?
Is it to boost his own ego?
To be like, look at these little babies?
Okay.
Get rid of these guys.
T-chain babysitting.
Yeah, but the super citizen was not a friend of them!
Like...
I'm pretty sure...
Whoa!
Probably farming resources.
We gotta farm resources?
What?
Oh, there's like one of them all the way back there.
Sniped them from all the way here.
Flexing his level, I guess.
It was nice though.
The C3 guy.
That was just like...
Being like, pick this up.
And I was like, yeeeah!
Oh, the resources are the samples I'm picking up.
Oh, I see.
I guess they like upgrade your ship and everything, right?
Helping newbies, I guess.
Oh my god, like true... like true...
Freedom fighters.
ART, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Go, go, Doki Bear!
This is great to watch!
FREEDOM!
Alright, go.
Can you actually get like... Can you actually die from the ship landing on you?
Is that possible?
We're super... like a true super citizen.
Babies, we did it!
We fucking did it, babies!
Babies!
Oh my god!
Look at us!
We fucking did it, babies!
We don't need a babysitter!
We are the babysitter!
Look at us go!
We even did the optional objective.
I cannot smell freedom.
We're fucking doomed.
Can we do that?
Oh, we didn't do that.
I didn't know how to do that.
Nice.
We had to multitask.
Whoa!
Five stars!
Yeah!
We got five stars!
Alright, our goal today is to unlock medium.
What?
He gets to level up and I can?
What did he do?
You!
The squad impact... zero?
Wait, was it fully liberated already?
Have we...
Have we colonized the planet and rid of...
rid of the anti-freedom monsters?
He did more democracy.
Oh, it's not liberate... liberated?
Oh, it's not liberate...
liberated?
Okay, where's my ship?
I need to get to the other ship.
I need to go to the other ship.
Oh, it's not liberated?
I got medium!
Let's go!
That's all I wanted!
See ya, suckers.
I got what I want and I'm leaving you.
There we go.
We're finally... we're finally teenagers now!
We've upgraded from babies to teenagers!
Or is it like tweens?
Are we tweens?
I feel like we're tweens now.
Guys!
From babies to tweens!
Let's go!
We're preteens!
We gotta upgrade our ship.
I threw them away like, I'm done playing with you.
Can I afford anything?
I can't!
I'm still too fucking broke!
Are you serious?
Guys, I'm still broke.
I can't afford anything.
Why do you guys want me to go?
You just want me to... Okay, change my ship.
Oh wait, this is...
Guys...
Why did you guys make me look at this when you know I'm broke?
Oh, I can purchase these!
Wait, I can!
Okay, wait.
What do I purchase?
I can buy the yellows.
Okay, orbital, galling, barrage...
Eoschafing, cluster bomb...
Precision...
Anti-personnel...
Supply pack...
What about allows you to distribute boxes?
Oh my god, I can be like...
Uber Eats.
Hello, Uber Eats here.
Doki Eats.
Hello, did anyone order some Doki Eats?
Doki delivery service.
Alright, which Eats?
What Ego do I get?
Ego cluster?
Or I'll get the Ego cluster.
Alright, I can afford it.
Hey Doki, I was at level 20 in your last match.
I didn't have a payment thing set up.
I'm a bit late on the job for this.
It was a really nice match.
Thank you!
Oh my god!
That's the super... Are you the super citizen?
You were the one that was listening to the lecture with me?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's him!
He was the one holding my hand to be like, pick this fucking shield up.
No, no, this one wasn't the medical student.
He was the other guy listening to the medical student.
He and I were both listening.
He was the super citizen just listening.
Alright, let's see.
Let's see.
R for weapons to unlock.
Okay, here we go, let's see.
Launch... Wait, you guys want to see robots.
What is the robots?
Okay, let's see.
Eliminate Charger.
Would it say like robots?
Activate Pums, Purge, Hatcheries...
Let's see, press R on the ship to spend medals.
Ooh!
On Fortnite battle pass?
Battle Pass?
I can spend it on Fortnite Battle Pass?
Where is it?
On the Super Store?
No.
Super Credits?
Okay, War Bounds.
Zero medals spent.
Do I go here?
What is this?
Can get better cape?
Ooh, wait.
What do I get?
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Let's see.
What can I afford?
I can afford...
Okay, wait.
I'm buying this.
No, it's locked!
No!
But this is the best one!
I like how you guys are like, get the gun!
And I'm just like, put the finger guns.
No.
You guys are like, Doki, no!
Get the gun, Doki!
And I'm like, finger guns?
Finger guns?
But finger guns are so much better!
What do you mean?
The finger guns is cooler!
You don't understand!
I regret clapping too.
No, I want to equip it.
No.
How do I equip?
I'm too scared.
Finger guns.
The finger guns is important!
You don't understand!
I'm so scared!
Because of that one person that was like, be careful, it might crash your game.
So I'm always like, scared now.
Okay.
What did I... I got like, a character.
Oh, I can like, have like...
Uh...
Oh, customization was... Okay, nice.
Wait, where's the...
Oh, nice.
There you go.
Clapping.
I want... that's good.
That's good that it's fixed.
They fixed it.
Okay.
Okay, it's randomized.
Oh no, I want to be brawny!
Alright, here we go.
Let's go.
Alright.
Let's see.
Are we at... we're at medium now.
We need to liberate this planet.
Alright.
We need to get...
What does it say?
Someone was like, we have to do the robots.
What does it... go to red area?
Here?
Is this not the red?
Oh, go to red area on the other side!
Oh!
Okay, defend.
Oh, is it here?
Okay, 44%.
These are all liberated.
Go to...
The creek.
Where the fuck is the creek?
Oh, here!
Alright, I'm at the creek.
Where do I go?
Okay, these guys.
Maybe don't...
Okay, they're level 2.
Level 18!
Okay, level 12.
Level 4.
Level 5.
Level 20.
What the fuck is this guy doing at level 20?
Level 2.
Yeah, we're not hanging out with the babies.
We're not hanging out...
Wait!
Okay, parent launch.
Wait, am I gonna regret it?
Wait, what do you mean?
I was there for the battle of the creek.
Okay, we be...
Okay, wait.
Level... Okay, I'll go here.
No!
I need... I need the...
Oh my god, there's a level 23 baby!
Okay, no!
Let me in!
I need somebody to... Oh my god, he's level 29!
Babysit... No!
Please!
Please, I need somebody to babysit me!
Please, that's all... What the fuck?
That's all I asked for.
Let me in.
Let me in!
Level 15.
Okay.
Level 14 and level... Okay, we'll do...
No!
Fine.
I'll do quick play.
But if I pick random, I might be in the baby squad!
And I want to be the only baby!
Evil, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
You can throw supply drop orbital strike markers on your friends.
Do what you will.
Oh my god, level 25!
Hey guys.
Level 50?
Whoa!
Hello there.
Oh, hey!
Helldivers to help pods.
Repeat, Helldivers to help pods.
There's a level 50?
How long you been playing this game?
Anyways, you're here to fight the robots, aren't you?
Hell yeah.
Hell yeah!
Yeah, I'm... alright.
I don't think he's confident.
Mission preparation aborted.
I've been watching your stream for a hot while now.
Oh my god!
Tell pods, go!
What?
Once you're ready, just help them to help out a pod.
Whatever.
Yeah!
Wait, how do I do this?
Oh, here you go.
There you go.
Where the fuck was your level 50?
They exist?
Just like...
They...
They exist?
Oh my god, look at him!
Look at his gear!
Shush, look at this guy.
Oh my god.
Bro, how the fuck do you get to the level...
This game came out like...
You know what?
That's okay.
How...
Well paid a babysit.
Lazy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Bro, he actually got the drip!
Bro!
Help pod launch initiated.
Hell drivers to help pod.
It's not uncommon.
How do you get in the server long enough to be level 50?
Sigma male grind set.
You're not... I'm not losing today, boys!
You guys were like, oh no, Doki's so fucked.
Like, oh no.
If everybody thinks that's the point of fighting the bugs, just learn how to take cover.
Learn how to take cover?
Guys...
I don't know... I don't think I'm that type of person.
Okay.
Oh my god.
There's so many...
I have a gun.
Okay.
Wait, I'm wearing a shotgun.
What am I doing?
I'm gonna get my... I'm gonna get my gun.
Okay.
Don't worry, guys.
You guys...
But yeah, the robots...
Alright.
Don't worry, guys.
Cover me!
I'm getting my machine gun!
Don't worry!
Alright.
Nice.
I got my machine gun.
Wait, can they shoot back?
Wait, they can shoot back!
Wooo!
That's what I'm talking about.
They can shoot back!
Wait, that's fucked up.
That's fucked up.
I just saw some guy explode behind me.
I've marked it on the map.
They have guns.
We'll be there.
Where do we go?
Right now.
Where's S4?
Surefour.
S4, we'll follow you!
I cannot stress how much of a fucking dragoon I am, donkey.
I've been watching you for a fucking year.
Oh shit, they're shooting!
If you're a dragoon...
If you die...
If you let me die, you get kicked.
A real dragoon wouldn't let me die.
Oh god.
There's so many things going on.
Don't worry, we're fine.
Wait, is that like a fucking Star Wars?
They'll just fucking...
They'll just drop it on us.
This thing...
It'll shoot them all down.
Oh shit.
They're shooting.
Is that like a fucking AT&T walker right there?
Guys, don't mind if we just wait here to do a quick... a big quick stop.
Defend or kick.
I can't speak fucking English.
Defend or kick!
Right now!
Also, hello, Doughkeeper and public squad Discord.
I know you're making fun of me right now.
What the fuck?
Bro.
Wait, are you also a fucking dragoon?
How the fuck did all of you snipe me?
How the fuck?
Oh my god, even the level 50 is a dragoon!
I learned it quickly!
Am I that easy to snipe?
Am I actually that easy to snipe?
I'm not.
Oh shit.
That's right, guys.
I ain't losing any time soon!
I don't know where I'm going.
I don't... I don't... I don't know where I'm going.
I got the side effect.
You guys can go for like the younger... the younger...
Okay.
S4, go do the thing.
We are everywhere.
90% of the Helldiver server is just drag goons.
You guys really didn't want me in the server, did you?
Hahaha.
Alright, nice.
We'll be fine.
Do I even need to shoot my gun?
The one guy that's not a dragoon is the one that's getting fucked over right now.
We did it!
Easiest mission of my fucking life.
Easy... Ow!
Wait!
You can get on fire?
I don't even know...
Okay, here we go.
We're good.
I don't even have to stream open anymore.
Ah!
We're not good!
Tap for map!
I
mean S4!
Where's S4?
S4, lead us!
You're the highest level!
Well, can't get in there.
There's the main objective.
So we gotta launch a nuke.
S4, lead us!
I'll never have to tap if I follow one person!
S4...
Oh my god, this is so easy.
I mean, this is...
This is so... Oh my god!
This is so easy.
Uh... Oh, there's the coach.
Look, I didn't think I'd... I didn't think I'd get shot!
Don't be so...
You're gonna wanna collect as many of those samples as possible, cause that's what you want to upgrade your ship in order to get buffed for your strategies and such.
Why do I have to pick it up if you guys can pick it up for me?
Wait, it's like... Okay, what the samples mean, chat, what the samples mean, I have to pick it up myself?
He's teaching us!
Free lesson!
We're dragoons, our legion.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you, Zach.
Okay, wait, it's shared?
It's in... Okay, I like how, like, the... It's shared and it's individual are both, like, right next to each other.
I...
I liked how... I liked how that's next to each other.
So it's like, what is it?
Oh, nice.
I'm getting so many lessons on this server alone.
It's all shared.
Start pulling up these boxes over here.
Everyone gets at the end?
Oh, so I don't have to do anything!
Oh, wait, let me shoot this one guy.
Nice.
Interact.
I'm doing it!
I'm doing my part!
I got a supply by the terminal if you need ammo.
I did it!
Open the silo!
Good.
I hate the creek.
I love the... What do you mean?
This is the fucking easiest game of my fucking life.
I don't... No!
T2!
Oh, why does this look like a...
The babies!
Oh, hey, I'm back.
It's like I never died.
I got to fucking do it, okay?
Where is he?
Alright.
We gotta kill this guy now.
Don't... No res!
Do not res him!
Do not res this man!
I'm gonna steal his gun.
We don't res him!
This is my gun now.
Where is he?
If you res him, I'm just killing him again.
I'm gonna kill him again.
Where is he?
Point me to the enemy.
We don't res him.
He doesn't come back.
But hey!
Congratulations.
S4, I swear to God.
We don't bring him back.
I saw him sitting here in heaven, lost in the river or something.
The dead don't talk!
No.
Wait, he's back!
Where is he?
The dead don't talk!
That's how you're right.
S4, you know what's good for you.
There we go.
Oh, it's so unlucky that there was some friendly fire there.
That was so unlucky.
No!
Oh, fuck!
Wait, we might lose this!
S4, we might lose this!
Oh, wait, we don't.
We win.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
We did it.
We're doing it!
We don't need to bring them back.
S4 and I, we're getting them back.
We're gamers!
Doki never forgets.
Alright, here we go.
We're good.
What do you mean?
Wait, he struck first!
I was just...
Look, he hit me first!
Guys, this was self-defense.
This was self-defense, guys.
Oh, no.
I was all about self-defending.
It's okay, S4 can carry us.
He ran in front of them, though.
Self-defense three times?
Yeah!
What are you trying to say?
Huh?
Nice.
I missed it.
What do you mean?
S4, I swear to god, S4.
Look at us go.
We're gamers.
We're gaming.
Wait, we get more points if we bring him back?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
We bring him back.
I love points.
Oh.
Oh, shit!
Don't worry.
No!
Guys!
Oh, fuck!
Guys, it's okay!
I'm coming back!
Look at that!
Team player!
Oh, shit!
Well, that's a good thing.
It's a good thing I brought people back, guys.
Ooh, let me pick this up and then let me pick this up.
Okay.
Oh, no, no, no!
Don't stand in front of me!
All right, we're good, we're good, we're good.
We're good.
What the?
I told you guys I can be a team player.
Whose gun is this?
It's my gun.
Oh, yeah, this is...
Holy shit.
I need reload.
I need reload!
Oh, shit, he's not dead anymore.
Oh!
All right.
We did it.
If you're a real dragoon, you get crushed by the ship.
If you want to get unmuted right now, get crushed by the ship right now.
I will only unmute if you get crushed by the ship.
Wait, you lose those points?
What do you mean?
S4 was willing to do it.
Die for me.
He's a real...
S4 was willing to do it.
A real one.
Liberty has seen you through.
He's the real one.
A true mad lad.
He survived.
S4, you selfless soul.
Loyal to the end.
A true freedom.
He survived.
Freedom Enthusiast.
Now we know...
who's really there for freedom.
Look at that!
I still got five stars!
I still got five stars after all the unfortunate accidents of self-defense.
Nicholas, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Look at that.
Stay muted forever.
Hey!
I said get crushed by the ship if you want to get unmuted.
I'm doing my part.
Lofa, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Still a second mission to do.
This is... democracy?
Hell yeah, brother!
Look at us go.
We're fucking gamers.
Alright, where's my ship?
Alright, see ya losers.
Wait, we're done.
Zachary, Sponger is truly the best of us.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Can you leave the game real quick?
I wanna play.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm gonna go.
Alright.
Here we go.
Thank you.
I did my part.
I'm doing so well, guys.
Alright.
Okay, the robots are scary.
Not gonna lie.
The robots are actually pretty scary.
I don't know.
I don't know if I wanna keep doing the robots.
Yeah, back to the... back to the bugs.
I feel like the bugs were definitely a lot safer.
The robots were a little scary.
That was... that was not cool.
That was not cool at all.
Alright, let's see.
What are some levels 3?
They're all babies.
Where are all the adults?
They're all like babies.
They're not even tweens.
Okay, doctor, bullet, and recovery FPS.
Alright.
I'll get babysat by like a teenage... a college student.
All of those lost hell dabbers were clearly traitors to democracy who stood in the way of Emperor President Doki.
Hey, guys.
I'm here to... Oh my god, another super citizen!
I'm here to leech off your mission.
I was here to leech it off.
Alright, what is this?
Clothes are bug holes.
Hey, guys.
I'm trying... I'm trying... guys, give me a sec.
I'm trying to... I'm trying to get my machine gun.
Oh.
Nice.
Oh!
Don't worry.
I can do this.
Boop.
Go higher difficulty.
It'll go well, I swear.
Okay, guys.
I have to get there first.
Oh my god!
He blew up my gun!
I'm coming back.
Hey, guys.
Oh, shit.
Guys, let me come up!
I wanna be cool just like you guys!
Ow.
Guys!
There you go.
Hello.
Are we supposed to... go somewhere?
Oh, we did it.
Oh my god, did I successfully leech off of you guys?
Sponger!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Oh, my god!
There's a level 50 chat!
The one that actually fucking...
got crushed by the ship for me!
We're not a cult, by the way.
We could be a religion.
For tax purposes.
No!
Shit!
Heal me.
Yeah, that's S4...
Where do we go?
Oh, my god!
It's Uber Eats?!
He has... he has the Uber Eats pack!
What's our church?
I don't know, I haven't filled up the forms to be legally a church.
Reload!
Oh, my god!
The Democracy Deliverer!
We're...
Nabi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We're definitely... No, we're not because we're not registered yet.
We're not... we're not registered yet to be a cult for tax purposes.
Because even though you're a cult, you can still be... you still like register as a church.
For...
For like... for no taxes.
So we can't be categorized as one yet.
Oh, hell boy.
Hell bomb.
What's happening?
How does she know this?
Because YouTube is like...
You can learn a lot from YouTube.
Because there was a YouTube content creator that wanted to legally be a church for like a day.
And then he like did all... like he was...
All you need is like a...
Place of worship.
You need like a place of worship and you have to like...
Get like a church.
And like you have to have like a sermon.
Hey guys.
I was a little stupid.
Hey, thank you guys.
I'm happy you guys let me leech off your mission.
Thanks everybody.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
Okay.
Just a little bit.
Guys, I lost my gun.
I don't know where he went.
I'm just gonna follow you.
No.
Wait, where is my things?
Where did I die?
I don't even...
Yeah.
Oh, there it is.
What?
If I die again?
Yeah.
Hello.
There you go.
I found it.
Nice.
Oh shit.
Let me...
Guys!
I won't step in another mine!
I swear to God!
Don't worry!
I'm here now!
Do not worry!
I feel bad because like...
I literally just like...
They didn't even want me here and I showed up.
It was like, please...
Take care of me.
They might be like on a fucking E-date right now and I just came in the third wheel.
Like...
If you think about it.
High five!
Thank you for the five gifted ships!
Thank you!
Please help.
They're like...
This is the child you never wanted.
Date later.
This is war!
There is no time for E-dates!
We're here to spread democracy!
Nothing like a democracy date.
Exactly!
Oh, a laser cannon.
Can I steal this?
Alright.
Where do we go?
D1 and R2.
Do you tell they are totally in a discord together right now?
Hey guys.
So like...
How you guys doing?
How is your E-date going right now?
I'm sorry for like...
Interrupting your couple time.
Uh...
And like...
Dying in the middle of your date.
So you're forced to revive me.
I'm sorry.
Democracy doesn't wait for callbacks.
Leave them alone, Doki!
What?
I'm trying to have a conversation!
LurkCrow says thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
They gotta spread enough democracy to earn the freedom to date on this planet.
If you take over leadership, I'm gonna go AFK for four minutes.
Bro!
Shit!
I have a third wheel!
Bro!
Guys... alright.
Well...
Here we go.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe I was the third wheel this entire time!
I was a joke!
You ruined the freedom date!
We need you to come back from your toilet break!
He can't lead us!
Oh my god.
Axeman!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Hi Doki!
I was the traitor who killed you!
Have fun spreading managed democracy into the galaxy!
Don't worry.
I'm already ruining the date right now.
Everything's going great.
It's everything I've always wanted.
Stop crying in the bathtub.
Stop.
Here we go.
Can we do this?
I can't believe it.
He even like gave leadership... to his date.
What's this?
The screen is frozen.
Oh shit, there's babies.
I like... how is he like able to just AFK?
Get out of the corner!
Alright, you know what?
Fuck this.
I'm just gonna... bye.
I'm just gonna... kill these guys.
No one close to us, right?
Nice.
We're fine.
Oh.
Get out!
Your laser is too slow!
I'm just gonna...
I should kill him before.
Please!
Come back from your toilet break!
Fine!
I'll heal myself!
Mission at 30 minutes remaining.
Activate terminal?
Are we activated yet?
Did you do it?
You're the leader.
Crying on the toilet from getting third wheeled.
Did you do it?
You're the leader!
I don't know what to do!
Think I know what to do!
Look!
He assigned you to be the leader!
Literally useless!
Look!
He assigned him to be the leader!
I'm just here to shoot my gun!
I'm just a leecher!
It's their day!
I'm just freeloading!
Are you doing it?
Are you doing it R2?
We did it!
I'm on the terminal.
Oh my god!
He's back!
He's back from his bathroom break!
Look at him go!
You need to help.
I am just here to shoot my...
Oh my god!
He's doing it!
Look at him!
Think it worked!
I bet like R2 was literally like screaming.
Was like screaming to his like duo and be like...
Oh my god!
She is not even fucking aligning anything!
She's literally just standing there!
He just watched me like not do anything.
I didn't know I was supposed to do this!
I was not given any instructions.
Look if there was no instructions given to me I don't know what to do.
I just shoot guns.
I was just waiting for D1 to come back.
Just standing there.
I bet you like normally people would just do like quick play and I'm just like freeloading other people's games.
Shouldn't have made your lobbies public!
That's on you!
If you didn't make your lobbies public I wouldn't be here!
Yeah, this is basically Starship Troopers.
God, it's so toxic.
What did we do?
Did we activate our stuff?
I'm cold, apparently.
Extreme cold.
You need to help so they can enjoy their date.
I am helping!
I'm giving them like... the true experience of freedom.
I'm giving them the freedom experience!
Public is freedom.
If they really didn't want me to interrupt their date, they would have made this a private lobby.
Objective, guys?
Guys, I know this is like a beautiful scenery to enjoy with your significant other.
But guys, come on.
I'll be here for a very long time if we don't complete the objective.
If you want me to leave, we gotta finish this objective, guys.
That's fucking right.
Check your map.
I did!
And I knew the objective was over there, but I wanted them to fucking...
I love... I really love the Uber Eats ability.
The hostage situation.
Watch them kick you before...
What do you mean?
I was... I'm contributing.
I'm doing my part.
I hope they used your church for the wedding.
Blue, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
They want you to watch their weird life.
Oh my god, it makes sense.
That's why their lobbies were public.
Oh my god, it makes sense now.
I was... they're freaks.
I was their plus one.
Oh yeah, there it is.
Nice.
Oh no, not another bug breach.
Is it just that way?
Okay, it's just over there.
It's not that many.
Which is good.
Oh wait, the nuke's coming.
The nuke's coming!
Just keep going!
Just keep running!
Oh, there's some bugs in front of us!
We're fine.
Yeah!
Freedom!
Liberty!
Alright, let's go.
I'm going back there.
I'm gonna go loot.
Is there no loot here?
Why is there so much light?
How can there be so much light if there's no loot?
Dude!
Okay, we're... it's like... up top.
See, look at that.
I looked at my...
I looked at my map, guys.
Look at that.
I looked at my fucking map for us.
Can I climb up?
No?
At least I can horse this.
I can horse this.
You can horse this!
It's possible!
No!
I can horse... I can horse this!
I told you it was possible.
I knew it was.
I knew it was Skyrim horseable.
Nice.
Oh, interact.
I'm gonna grab some ammo.
This?
I'm gonna do it.
Did I do it?
It just works.
I'm on the tunnel.
Oh.
There you go.
I did it, guys.
Huh?
Guys.
Guys, someone else needs to do this.
Hahaha!
The leader!
Leader, do it, leader!
Hahaha!
Do it, leader!
Wait, I don't think the...
I think the leader is struggling too.
We can watch him struggle together, guys.
Oh my god, he did it!
Alright.
Manually adjust flow rate values.
Are you doing it?
Okay.
Oh my god, D1.
Go do your job!
It didn't even take one.
Hahaha!
He's a genius!
He's so smart!
Oh my god, he's going to the other valve now!
Hahaha!
Oh shit, I need a help.
I need to help him.
Don't worry.
I'm going to let the leader do it.
I know what my job is.
Hahaha!
And it's not useless!
I'm not useless, guys!
I swear!
I'm shooting my gun.
Ah!
I can't be useless if I'm shooting my gun, guys.
Hahaha!
If you think about it...
Good job guys, thank you.
Hahaha!
It sounded so condescending.
It actually did sound condescending.
Good job guys.
What did you expect?
What do you mean?
If I give us the loot, then he'll know I'm trying my best.
I did it.
Your job is standing there and being like, did you do it?
That's my job.
It's this way.
Okay, I know where to go guys.
Guys, I know where to go.
Is it this way?
Doki say thank you to your babysitter.
Guys, we're a team.
Just remember that before you do anything.
We're a team.
Wait, what are they doing?
They don't want to do the extraction?
What are they doing?
Are they writing an angry letter to my manager?
Are they trying to vote kick me?
Right now?
Are they trying to vote kick me before we leave?
Please no.
I'll give you guys supplies.
Do you guys like supplies?
Oh wait, whoops.
I'll give you guys supplies guys.
Look.
Boop.
I don't have ammo.
I can't even do my one job.
Nice.
Look, see?
I gave him supplies.
He can't be mad at me anymore.
Officer, that's her over there.
Alright, here we go.
We're coming over.
I'm useful.
What are they doing?
Are they doing the side objective?
You're in the marriage.
If they can take care of me, they can have a child.
I'm the child test.
It's like how like parents are like, oh, can we take care of a...
Should we have a kid?
And then they were like, no, we have to...
We have to make sure we...
Let's get a dog first.
So we know if it's possible.
You know, I'm that.
I'm the dog.
I'm the dog test.
Like the egg test.
Yeah.
But like instead, I'm the dog test, which is even better.
If they can take care of me, they can handle a child.
What side quest are they trying to do?
How can...
Whoa!
Oh shit.
No, I'm poisoned.
It's okay.
I'm fine.
I know you guys are so worried about me too.
I know.
I know you guys are very worried about me, guys.
Now I can like fully reload this.
Nice.
Guys, what side quest are you guys trying to do?
The extraction point is like right next to us.
Okay.
That's fine.
We're fine.
Guys, the extract...
Guys, I don't know if you guys know this, but the extraction is available, guys.
I don't know if you guys know this, but the extraction is, is very available.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh!
There we go.
Guys!
Are you guys done?
Yeah!
He's gonna be on his way.
Wait, me?
Wait, which way is extraction?
Wait, what?
Guys!
Wait!
It's like he knew!
I already forgot which way was extraction.
Who's fucking beating me up?
Okay.
It's like this way.
Oh, it is.
Bro!
He knew!
Sorry guys, I bounced off the hill.
Thanks man.
Thanks.
Look, he said sorry.
I guess.
Oh my god.
He failed the baby test.
Guys.
Guys, I don't know.
He failed the baby test, guys.
I tried to run!
What do you mean?
I swear to god!
Oh god!
Guys, I think...
I think he's done.
I think he wants the state to be over.
I don't know.
I have a feeling.
Oh shit!
I killed 150 enemies!
Let's go!
I did what I've always wanted to do.
Ruined somebody's date.
He is done, baby.
Sick.
No!
Stop!
Stop poking me!
Yeah.
We're almost there.
Extraction is so far.
I don't know.
The baby bounced off the hill.
Nice.
Well, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you!
Thank you.
And then thank you for the super chat.
Mom, Dad!
I want to go home.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I made them break up!
Look.
If I was the one that broke their marriage, then maybe they were never compatible in the first place.
Okay?
I am not the main reason.
Listen, I was the breaking point.
Wanna do it?
Yes, but also...
I was like the one that pushed them off the edge.
But it doesn't mean that I was the sole cause of this.
Why do you sound proud of that?
I didn't say I was proud of it.
I'm just saying.
It's not my fault that they broke up.
I was just there.
Doki opening marriage counseling.
Steven, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, Tia, thank you for the 20 gift-a-shifts.
Alright, woah, WOAH!
WOAH!
HE ALMOST KILLED YOUR WIFE!
Guys, this isn't good.
I don't think they're gonna last any longer.
Oh my god, he actually almost nated him.
He actually almost...
Can you convince your teammates to turn off the game of trying to fight for freedom?
Gator, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's all going wrong.
It's all going wrong!
Everything's going wrong right now!
Okay.
Oh no.
It's okay, I have my shotgun.
It's alright!
We're fine!
The ship's coming down!
It's almost freedom hours!
I just have my pistol!
Alright, here we go.
We're doing it, we're doing it.
Nice.
Goodbye.
Stoops, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
We
did it!
For freedom!
Yay!
Guys, you know what?
I think they'll make it in the end.
I feel like they're gonna make it.
We did it, chat!
We did it!
Four stars?
No!
I love it!
Only four stars.
But why?
We did so much!
Freedom from marriage.
I don't understand!
We couldn't get five because of...
Hey!
I don't know what you're talking about.
I didn't do anything wrong.
I didn't do anything.
I can't do anything wrong if I didn't do anything.
If you think about that.
No impact.
True.
Why can't I leave?
Oh, okay.
I was just standing behind this man.
Alright, see you guys.
Good luck with your marriage.
I got hard!
Difficulty.
Because I realized that sounded weird out of context.
Alright, I think this was a good time.
I got...
Wait.
Oh, he has finger guns?
Oh my god.
Pearl still has Belle and the Beast.
Now DNR.
Chucho.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, guys.
I think this is a good time to call it here.
I think saving a marriage is a good way to end today's stream.
I hope you guys had a fun time watching.
That's fun though.
It's really fun.
Just like encountering all these different people today.
We encountered so many different people today.
Man, I had a lot of fun.
I hope you guys had fun watching too.
Thank you everybody.
Thank you guys.
That was...
That was actually like...
That was honestly like really, really fun.
I'm really glad that I got to...
I got to try out Helldivers.
Alright, guys.
You guys can...
I gave you guys one spot in the Helldivers server.
Good luck.
Good luck to that one person that gets to fight for freedom.
Good luck to you.
Oh, yes!
For those who don't...
Before I call it here.
Tomorrow is gonna...
I'll be streaming on Twitch.
For the PAL World's Twitch Rivals.
And my team is going to be...
Surefour, ShyLily, and this little indie slime called P.O.P.
I think that...
I don't really know...
How to pronounce her name.
But I saw that she won a PAL World competition.
So I invited her to join us.
So, yeah.
So, I am very excited.
To play...
To... I just...
Honestly, I don't really care if we get last.
Because what I love about Twitch Rivals...
Is that no matter what placement you get...
You get automatic money.
It's just...
No matter...
You know...
No matter what placement...
We still win money in the end.
And like last...
For last place...
You win like $500.
So I was like...
What?
I'm fine with that.
I was just like...
Money is money.
It's...
Yeah, it's pure profit.
So like...
I'm just here...
I just want to have fun.
I just want to have like fun...
With people.
Oh yeah.
Shallow and I were actually supposed to...
We were going to collab next week.
So...
But then I asked her...
Because I had like an extra spot.
And I was like...
Oh, do you want to join?
Because like she actually was...
Was originally trying to join...
PAL World Twitch Rivals.
But like her team...
Um...
They couldn't get like a team together in time.
Uh...
Last minute.
So then like she was actually supposed to do PAL World Twitch Rivals.
But then like she had their team ended up like dropping out at the end because they couldn't find enough people.
So I was like...
Oh hey, I still have a spot.
Do you want to join me?
And she's like...
Yeah.
So I was like...
Yeah, nice.
Um...
Uh...
So yeah.
Um...
And I'm going to be having a collab with Shia Lili next week.
I don't really know the details because we're still organizing it.
But yeah.
There's a lot of fun things.
There's a lot of fun things that are coming up for uh...
Next week too.
Uh...
So yeah.
That is what's happening for tomorrow.
It's a two day event.
Uh...
We don't know what the achievements are that we're supposed to get.
They're going to give us like a list of achievements that we're supposed to uh...
Like...
Like fight for.
Like you know like whichever team has the most achievements by X amount of time basically wins uh...
Basically like uh...
Wins or something.
Get like ranked and stuff.
Um...
So we're supposed to find out like 15 minutes of stuff.
But then we're going to have to figure out like an hour and a half of stuff.
We're going to have to do like an hour and a half or so before the tournament starts.
And so those are the rules.
But they're already people?
It's so funny.
I was looking at the discord and I was like reading the rules and they're already people that were like can we...
Like can we exploit?
Can we exploit and do like speedrun strats and stuff like that.
And it was so funny because the staff was like...
No.
Because they were like, can we do this speedrun track?
Can we do that speedrun track?
Can we do this exploit?
And then Sam was just like, no, no, no, no, no!
And I thought it was so funny, I was like, what the fuck?
People are already training for this!
And I was like, bro, it's just PAL World!
Yeah, I was like, holy shit, this is like, this is so sweaty already!
That is crazy!
It's so competitive!
I didn't realize how competitive it was gonna be!
Because it's like, it's just like an achievement run.
But yeah, they're like fucking brainstorming like speedrun strats right now in the PAL World, like Twitch Rivals Discord.
I was just like, holy fuck!
I just wanted to fuck around and have fun!
But like, honestly, whatever placement we get, I just hope to have lots of fun!
With old and new friends.
Oh yeah!
Also like, I'm not sure when we're gonna be debut- like when it's gonna be up on the store!
But we do have the Lunar New Year merch fully done.
But it's not on the store yet, because we're still like setting some stuff up.
Here's a little preview for that.
So that's gonna be on the merch store.
It's gonna be soon, because we're still setting stuff up.
But yeah, so there's gonna be an acrylic stand, some button badges, some stickers, the pillow, the red pocket envelopes.
And then like, there's gonna be a limited bundle.
This is gonna be a limited set.
Except for the red pocket envelopes.
The button badges, stickers, acrylic stand, pillow is a limited run.
But yeah, we're gonna be doing that.
But the red pocket- because it's like themed around Year of the Dragon.
So like, this is themed around Year of the Dragon and everything.
Red pocket envelopes aren't, but because it's themed around Year of the Dragon, it's gonna be a limited set for- Like, as in like a limited run.
Not just a set, but like, it'll be over- the pre-orders are gonna stop at a specific month.
And then it's not gonna be brought back.
And it's not gonna be staying in the store forever.
But the red pocket envelopes will stay in the store forever.
Since I feel like- Since the red pocket envelopes isn't like specific to like the Year of the Dragon.
Um...
But yeah!
I'm not sure when that's gonna be on the store.
But just a little update for you guys.
Uh...
Yeah everybody!
I hope you had a lot of fun!
Hope you guys did too.
Anyway, I'm gonna call it here cause I actually have so much work to do today.
Uh... but as always everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you...
...sit for me...
...head to bed.
Cause you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everyone!
Bye guys!
Bye!